geil hat funktioniert sebastian liebt
sie wir lieben sie und die industrie
erst recht geprüfte snacks der in ihnen
steckt ordentlich heiße luft die die
kasse klingeln lässt
500 prozent preisaufschlag sind damit
drin
wir zeigen wie gesund die snacks
wirklich sind und wieder puff trick
funktioniert kino oder amaranth als
müsli oder in der waffel überall finden
wir geprüfte körner besonders deutlich
wird der preisunterschied allerdings
beim reis das naturprodukt kostet knapp
3 euro pro kilo
die geprüfte version hingegen fast 17
euro pro kilo möglich macht das ein
explosiver trick und wie der
funktioniert weil es nur einer
sebastian liegen
jetzt knallt gleich richtig der
produktentwickler kennt die tricks der
industrie denn er hat sie mit erfunden
wir haben eine selbstgebaute kanone
alles was stärker haltig ist ein
bisschen wasser noch enthält also
restfeuchtigkeit lässt sich super
aufrufen
und das funktioniert so die kölner
werden mit etwas wasser auf bis zu 300
grad erhitzt dadurch entwickelt sich ein
heisser dampf der die weichen könne
zusammendrückt wird der druck
schlagartig aus der kanone entladen
profi stärken kann auf und wir erhalten
fertigen puffreis also körner und wasser
in die trommel und los geht's oder fehlt
noch etwas sebastian ganz wichtig eine
leder dichtung weil es darf er vorher
nicht ein bisschen druck verloren geht
damit bei den schlagartigen befreien
auch alles auf platz in seiner kanone
wird sebastian gleich bis zu 35 bar
erzeugen wir werden das noch häufiger
sagen aber bitte macht das nicht zu
hause nach
münchen
[Musik]
minute
ja geil der sind die geprüften
reiskörner sauber das ergebnis
akzeptabel ich freue mich da bist du
nicht allein sebastian auch für die
industrie ist die technik ein echt
profitabler glücksgriff denn mit einem
schlag lassen sich die kölner auf das
zehnfache ihre ursprünglichen größe
aufrufen
für eine packung reis waffe braucht man
so nur noch gut 200 reis könne
oder wie die industrie sagt leider geil
aus einer packung naturreis werden
geprüft
zehn packungen ua la eine
preissteigerung von 5 100 prozent aber
warte mal zerstört die explosion nicht
wichtige inhaltsstoffe ja unsere labor
untersuchungen zeigen ein klares
ergebnis dass vitamin b1 und die
wichtige folsäure in den reis können den
deutlich verloren
das gilt übrigens auch für geprüften
quinoa buchweizen oder dinkel
doch das größere problem liegt woanders
oft werden den geprüften können honig
zucker und schokolade zugesetzt
aus den scheinbar gesunden snacks werden
wahre kalorienbomben die luftnummern aus
der puff kanone schmecken so zwei
knusprig fein
doch für diesen spaß sagen wir
ordentlich drauf mehr tricks checks und
duell aus der welt der lebensmittel
findet ihr auf unserem kanal zdf besser
essen